i think we're facing a very serious
crisis in this country man
i do too since the clinton email scandal
yeah so
hillary clinton destroyed public record
she her her team i should be very
careful uh her people destroyed
using bleach bit purged the server
hammers and phones hammers on phones
destroying them
abnormal after she was subpoenaed to
turn it over yeah
nothing happened nothing yeah she is
still romping around
romping about super wealthy joe biden we
see this is happening
and you know i talk i tell you why i
think we're headed for a very very
serious crisis
you've got a large group of people who
understand the media is lying about
literally everything
okay when i say literally i mean
figuratively i mean literally i
i don't think they've told the truth
once well no no no in politics
but like when the new york times talks
about certain things of course i'm
literally using
abc of course you know i think it's
partisan either because like
the war in in the middle east and then
halliburton dick cheney's company
goes in and makes billions of dollars
off and joe biden's brother in iraq
makes millions of dollars in boeing
sponsors meet the press and uh
msnbc is owned by general electric which
supplies
weaponry and um excuse me uh you know
tools to the military that they make a
lot of money off
chemical makes pharmaceuticals and high
fructose corn syrup
yeah only they make a ton i don't know
about that no you guys want to know the
real conspiracy
there's a the real conspiracy
the real beauty campaign from dove oh
yeah
about this you've seen it right all the
women they're like you know
plus-sized models i remember this this
you know who owns dove big thing who
unilever do you know what other company
that unilever owns oh no
ben and jerry's oh my goodness you know
what my conspiracy theory is
what if biden is faking his cognitive
decline and he's actually a very sharp
criminal mastermind
he just doesn't want to get put on the
stage
that's what i said he's going to wonka
us yeah it's going to be inauguration
date he's going to be like looking all
silly and then
he's going to fall backwards do a
perfect like backward somersault and
then be like
no i got you i'm back baby i'm joe biden
this country is mine and then a bunch of
like chinese guys run out and they're
like making it rain oh man
anyway i'm looking forward to this we've
got a bunch of uh uh
now that we just made everything sound
silly aren't we
serious we have to laugh or we're gonna
cry this is let's see how long have you
been corrupt and since nixon
knows
james rosen was investigated by the
department of justice eric holder uh as
a possible criminal co-conspirator
because he was reporting on the news fox
news said we are outraged to learn today
that james rosen was named a criminal
co-conspirator
for simply doing his job as a reporter
obama prosecuted more whistleblowers
and leakers than i believe all other
presidents combined
this guy obama not good on civil
liberties i thought he was going to
steal the patriot act man yeah well he
he talked he talked about all that all
the civil libertarianist
things that he tended to do and then he
got in office and his administration did
a bunch of things that he supposedly
didn't know about that was the excuse
that we heard for
about eight years i remember my favorite
was in the irs was targeting
uh and auditing conservative leaning
organizations and that was just
something the president
didn't know anything about like if
donald trump had done that that would be
creeping fascism but obama did i was
like
well he just didn't know guys you know
he wore a tan suit and you freaked out
about that this is basically the same
thing
i love somebody tweeted don't you don't
you remember like don't you wish for the
days when the only
scandal was obama's tan suit oh my god
yeah and i'm like i know right like you
know he
wore a tan suit and ordered a drone
strike on a civilian restaurant yemen
that killed a 16 year old american
citizen but he wore tan suit can you
believe it what was it like
over 3 000 illegal drone strikes under
his administration well
trump has up drone strikes and he
deserves criticism for trump's 100
percent
his first test in yemen he's kept as
aiding the saudis and the
human rights atrocities they're
committing in yemen he's done bad things
trump's
first several years very bad and john
bolton huge mistake
one of the first things that trump did
when he got in was he ordered a commando
raid in yemen which resulted in the
death of a little girl
so so trump has his his foreign policy
blunders as well
i'm looking at the current trend of
these peace agreements and withdrawing
our troops and i'm like keep doing that
and
you know you've got my support obama
however was a hawk
on a boat oh a hawk dude come on he was
some kind of
strange hook frankenstein flying monster
that was breathing he was fired
he was literally a human drone he's a
human drone well no
are we allowed to say really awful
energy jokes we are right i think i
don't know i don't hear joe
i know you're going to get me in trouble
you want to hear us in trouble you want
to hear an obama era
yes it's about war it's not about race
or anything you guys should be sure
sure yeah just replace any words with
any other ones
it's a it's an obama era joke the left
we're going to cut tim's mic no i'm
kidding
what's the difference between a school
and a terrorist headquarters oh no
i don't know i just fly the drone oh
that's horrible oh god
that's horrible but no there that's
what's that's another obama era joke
that's an obama-era joke
it's horrible but there's due to the
fact that there were a lot of civilians
killed
under obama's watch despite the fact
that he talked a big game about wanting
to bring about world peace despite the
fact that he won nobel peace prize
i love him everyone then you know what
he did when they started killing
uh civilians they were like well you
know
those guys they're adult men yeah so
military age men yeah so not civilians
yeah that was that was the place it's
horrific
that's horrific obama bad george bush jr
obviously middle east wars they're all
back
right but isn't it isn't it kind of
interesting that we were just discussing
earlier some of the foreign policy
blunders which have taken place under
trump which is like kind of uh an
understanding yeah but but but the
reality is
he has been less hawkish than any other
president of my lifetime certainly
uh that said funny that the media hasn't
criticized him for
any of that stuff it's funny that the
media hasn't criticized that for any of
the people who have died because of his
foreign policy
no it's not i didn't know anything about
a drone strike upage
yeah yeah definitely yeah no we never
heard it
don't you realize when joe biden gets
elected he's gonna he's it's gonna be
tenfold man yeah he's gonna
light the floor dude i was talking to
i was talking to somebody i knew who was
like it's time you know everybody you've
got to go and vote for
joe biden to stop this and i said
something like i was like
i can totally understand why people
don't like donald trump you know his
character
and some of the things he's done blah
blah and then i was just like you're
just never going to be able to convince
me
to vote for the guy who was vice
president while
they were blowing up kids yeah and the
response was what do you mean blowing up
kids
exactly what do you mean blowing up in
new york
someone some activist did this art where
it was one of these like
nypd advertisements yeah and it showed
you know that you know that silhouette
image of like the father and the kids
and they're holding hands and running
it's like a
immigrant thing yeah and then it showed
a drone of flying above and like a line
with a missile flying towards them did
reagan get us into new war
reagan was sealing warhawk i don't think
i was alive i wasn't
i was barely oh yeah i was two carter
when he left carter the media hated
and i think he really didn't get us into
much war jimmy carter before
he was probably a bit more dumb she did
i mean i'm not a fan of carter but he
definitely was not as much of a hawk
based on what he needed to trash that
guy like he's thought of as the worst
president
peanut farmer i mean i'm not a fan of
him at all but i hear you right now
we have it was really funny someone i
saw some some leftist post on facebook
that obama didn't get us into any new
wars what
and i was like what did you say that
syria what are you talking about
anything up libyan intervention in syria
just right off the back what do you mean
like no about yemen yeah what about the
fact that he decided he wanted to
placate the saudis after making a deal
with the iranians
and now cash yeah that you can call
vietnam's wasn't a war that's what's
crazy about it it was a military
action because right they didn't have
congressional systems or there was not
congressional
never declared war so you didn't have to
declare war to kill hundreds of
thousands
it wasn't a war we just killed hundreds
of thousands of people and sent our
troops over there
yeah a bunch of them died as well there
was a really great article and i think
this was in the intercept actually which
we'll
we'll get into next that said something
like it for
you know strangely for the first time in
several decades the president
is trying to withdraw forces and it's
congress trying to stop him
whereas historically the president has
been trying to deploy forces and
congress has been trying to stop him
keeping the forever wars going to own
trump and now
you know the craziest thing is when i
hear these like lefty friends of mine
being like
well actually we definitely need a
presence in syria actually
yeah no joke we we must maintain a
presence because we're a rush of fear
no because of we must defend the kurds
i've noticed this as well actually that
there's a
friend of mine i won't give too much
information but he has always just been
very to the left and he was always
very against the wars from day one i
remember that seemed to be his primary
issue under the the bush administration
he was always talking about how we
shouldn't be involved in the middle east
and now he's criticizing trump for not
wanting a presence in syria
that makes him a russian puppet it's
insane it's completely insane like
people completely flip on their values
and you would think that anti-war thing
like you would think the anti-war thing
would be something the left would stick
to
there's i wish yeah
explaining why we don't want to just
pull every troop out all at once right
because it creates a vacuum that then
will be filled by like
terry warlords and things by the people
we create by the people we function
exactly yeah
that's the problem we created but
pulling out isn't the solution
no no no no you're incorrect he said
that
we absolutely need some kind of presence
but we can pull it that we can we can
draw it down like significantly without
yeah
well he said we can take a lot of our
current forces out of these places and
still maintain a small enough presence
to prevent the vacuum from creating
like my friend who was in the military
in afghanistan charles maxwell shout out
charles if you're watching uh
said they just don't want to fight those
guys the iraqis the afghanis they just
don't not only did they not really for
the most part they didn't want to fight
they
they didn't know how they were it's not
our responsibility
what we created exactly listen listen
you know i think it was ron paul who
said
something like my man he said something
like people keep saying oh but if we
pull out now this that or that will
happen and he goes when you're a doctor
and you've given someone the wrong
medication you don't simply say well we
better just keep you on it you say we
better get you off this yes
and so there's been no effort in my
opinion at least to do something about
this
and at a certain point look i understand
there's there's bigger arguments about
oh the chinese will move in or russia
will move in or whatever and it's like
you know what man
do the american people agree that we
should be
funding sending our you know men and
women in uniform
overseas just to live and build roads
and build cities there
and be effectively the government
because the people there don't want to
run it
i don't think they do no of course not
but the problem is when you elect a
president who says i'm going to end our
forever wars
and then he tries and congress blocks
him it's clear
based on what we see with the media what
we're seeing with joe biden when he gets
away with what the fbi who they
prosecute who they don't
how michael flynn gets gets charged how
you get all this russiagate nonsense you
know
it's a big club and you ain't in it you
can see who is and as long as you
support their war machine
you're good so when donald trump ups
jones strikes you didn't even hear about
it
nope it's because they can't criticize
that because then what happens if when
if slash when joe biden wins and then
they're going to be like hey remember
you talking about jones strikes what's
what's biden doing oh well
we like them now well that's the thing i
mean joe biden is such a hawk he was
pushing for war in iraq as far back as
1997.
can you explain yeah keep going sir um
well what i wanted to get into really
was the fact that
we were gloating in the late 70s about
the fact that we had
essentially given russia their
quote-unquote own vietnam by getting
them
involved in the middle east and by
funding the mujahideen yeah
and there were some people arguing that
part of the reason that this actually
accelerated the collapse of their
government it
increased social instability uh they
were spreading themselves too thin by
trying to be involved in this region
whether or not you agree with all that
it's kind of ridiculous that our
strategy was to get them involved in the
middle east and fund
uh different terror groups which we
didn't call them back then
we just called them rebellions yeah
rebellions freedom fighters now we're
fighting them they're terrorists
um but we seem to think that it would be
the worst possible
possible thing for russia to get
involved in that region so we tried to
get them involved and we funded their
enemies and then we literally fell into
the same trap like a decade later and
we're still there
yep now i get it and we're also fighting
the people we
like gave weapons yeah like this is a
repeating pattern though right we
created al qaeda and then we created
isis
the idea is of limited war they won't
they want limited war
we don't have total wars basically
they're trying to avoid a world war
sort of but also there's this really
insidious thing where so when you look
at what happened
in libya and the fact that
we decided for whatever reason that uh
having gaddafi remain in power was no
longer
uh something that was politically
advantageous for do you want like some
kind of uh
african union of some sort or something
i'm not i'm not he wanted yeah i'm not
exactly
i know that i don't i'm not exactly sure
what the reasoning was but i know that
they ended up funding a coup against him
and
essentially the people dragged him out
into the street castrated him sodomized
him and
murdered him i mean i apologize but the
reason i'm being graphic here is because
this is something that obviously we
could never do to a foreign leader right
with our military but if we fund a coup
that does something horrifically cruel
to a foreign leader maybe we're just a
little bit more intimidating
but we haven't violated the geneva and
then if you ever want to go in and
overthrow them they did some horrible
war crimes so yeah man you got an excuse
after all that happened i know some
people who are doing work with
in like diplomacy international
relations and i was told one story about
how after libya was completely
destabilized
you had essentially a goblin king type
scenario
where uh you know you know how the
goblin king works no to become goblin
king you kill the goblin king and then
you're
oh that's right so it's a cycle of just
kill and then everyone piling the bodies
on top and trying
the roman empire so you had all these
different militia groups different sects
constantly fighting taking over and
there was one point where when they
finally got a i'm doing air quotes here
stable government yeah one of the
militias just walked in for a meeting
and pulled a pen on a grenade and
slammed it on the table oh like that was
one of the stories i heard from one of
these people working
like yeah wow dude it's crazy yup like
we're in charge now
grenade on the table and that's the sad
thing it seemed or
i should say it seems or it has seemed
um for a number of years that no matter
which party is in power
this is ongoing but trump has actually
been trying to to remove us from this
and i don't know if it's because he has
these sort of bleeding heart
humanitarian concerns that we might have
but he realizes that this isn't good for
the american people
yeah it's a waste of money it's a waste
of money the the reason
and a waste of human life and it
increases social instability it's
there's nothing there for us right
after world war ii so i think to explain
the counterpoint a little bit
uh they created the military industrial
complex dwight d eisenhower
talked about where they started building
american military bases all over the
world
to prevent world war three because world
war ii happened because
everybody was isolated one country now
we have two dukes and now
right now every bunch of people have
nukes and we have all these military
bases and the fear is if we
disarm and withdraw that another country
will
just fill that gap yep and maybe they
would
that's that's the could you imagine if
some other country was trapped in a
two-decade-long foreign entanglement
that was draining their resources
military bases in canada and in mexico
and nuclear submarines off the coast of
washington dc i mean could you that's
literally like what we've got over there
it's crazy
right right right i'm saying we i think
it's time we bring
our troops home and you know what i'd be
willing to have you know in that
conversation with sean parnell
maintaining
a much much toned down presence just to
prevent
you know isis from forming and things
like that well it's funny
there's this whole debate over whether
or not we should have a tiny presence
there or no presence there
i think we should cross that bridge when
we get to it let's just get the presents
limited to some degree before we debate
whether or not we should completely
remove ourselves from these regions with
diplomacy with china and russia
let's just not start a new war like this
every ten years and he hasn't
and their first president the first
president in 40 years
the first president in four years to not
start a new war and on top of that this
is hilarious they start saying without
any evidence that he was colluding with
the russians
and we saw back in 2012 romney in who
who is
the poster boy for the neoconservative
foreign policy and sort of establishment
conservatism
trying to push for for uh an escalation
of tensions with russia
claiming that they're our next big
foreign policy threat the democrats have
also adopted that position now and isn't
it awfully convenient that that's the
foreign power that they claim trump was
conspiring with without any evidence
because when he doesn't want to escalate
tensions with them
oh that's just proof that's just
evidence that he's really working for
them
yep wow or when he says i don't want a
missile strike he's doing what putin
wants
yeah putin's bidding can you believe can
you stop for just one moment everybody
listening hear these words
just think about how the past four years
and even to this day
they are saying that donald trump is
secretly working for vladimir putin
psychotic my favorite thing psychotic so
you all heard about tucker carlson
and you know his documents go missing
yeah yeah yeah tucker never said
he didn't have any copies he never said
that and i actually
uh was talking someone mentioned to me
there are copies it's just i guess
tucker's point was we were shipping
documents and someone intercepted them
now apparently ups found them which
makes sense someone wanted to see what
he had they went through it they put him
back
if that's the case i made copies of them
but uh jonathan
for new york mag writes tucker says he
lost the only copies
of evidence that would nail biden he
never said that media is at it again he
never said that
and more importantly jonathan chait is
the guy who went on msnbc and said
that it's possible donald trump was a
russian asset since 1987.
of course it's possible no no no no no
no no possible no no that would imply
donald trump was a soviet asset
we talked the soviet union is secretly
still in existence
it's possible that he has like 30 cows
in his power right now
could you imagine this idea that like
trump was an asset of the soviets
and the soviet like institutions are
still in effect poland is just keeping
it secret and we don't know
and all the people who live there don't
know either well it's hilarious because
he's giorning east germany well that's
right
that is like the most paranoid far right
conspiracy theory
i've ever heard in my life
like the ussr is still operating and the
president of the united states
i believe that russia has spread her
errors but the idea that they're still
functioning as a communist government in
some limited capacity that the president
of the united states is their puppet is
totally insane
i guess or maybe maybe they could be
arguing that after the ussr fell apart
uh there was new management and trump
just decided to stick around i don't
know
so i'm not sure why he would have been
loyal to the communist government in the
first place
i don't understand it because he's
wanted money wanted money
yes yeah i don't know you should be
upholding russia in my opinion as a
beacon of possible hope
of what you can do with a communist
regime what you can do no no
no they democratize their their country
i don't know
the soviet party and then oligarchs went
around with guns
same in the united states we've got
oligarchs running you know the craziest
the craziest thing is
let me tell you a story about the
russians the crazy thing is about the
fall of the soviet union and i'm far
from an expert but i have a friend
uh i i know people who who are in you
know ukraine and and uh people from
poland and stuff
i asked like how is it that you know
ukraine has all these oligarchs people
who have you know
ridiculous sums of money they're wealthy
by american standard like they're
billionaires you know
and the people of ukraine their gdp like
they make an average of like 400 bucks a
month
and i had a friend who told me after
communism collapsed all of a sudden you
had these communist workers
in a factory shrugging at each other
what do we do
how do we like do we keep making stuff
and then all of a sudden one day a guy
walks in with two other dudes in the out
of guns
and he says we're gonna tell you what
you do you take orders from me now
and they went ugh you got it boss and
that was it
there was no more power it was a vacuum
so the dudes who picked up the guns went
around and just
took the factories and then it was
theirs
you know i tried to watch a documentary
about the
transition from the soviet to the what
do you call it the democratic
republic of russia what is it the united
states federation
and it's uh the dude with the gorbachev
and he in like a group
yeah didn't he do a pizza hut commercial
and it was like this huge
big thing i think you're right yeah yeah
i remember seeing a clip of that yeah
they basically
hey did you know that uh did you know
that trump did a domino's commercial yes
so he did a pizza commercial
did everyone working for the ussr get a
pizza hut deal cool yeah
no that was the fall of the communist
party my point about the the transition
from the soviets to the the russian
federation is that it was very uh
obfuscated i don't know
how it happened what happened and maybe
it was behind the scenes a bunch of
oligarchs you know
the craziest thing was i don't know if
you was it you telling me this who told
me this oh no it's like it was michael
malus
that after the fall of communism and
these documents
like these dossiers and all the people
were released like their darkest secrets
there was just like a code of silence
where everyone
knew like the really awful things others
had done and just agreed not to bring it
up because everyone knew what they did
too
it's like a really crazy thing anyway
yeah donald trump not an asset of the
soviet union sure
no we don't know that for sure possible
a lot of things are possible it's
possible that you wrote one zero one
percent
it's possible that uh all of the
pollsters are colluding with each other
as possible
and laughing and saying at a one add a
one change that negative to a plus
it's possible only high five we actually
wouldn't know it's true wouldn't it be
funny if like all the polls are actually
inverted
and they're and they're like oh we got
another one it's minus five for biden
just put another line to the minus
it's like plus five for button
it's gonna be it's gonna be interesting
nonetheless um i'm looking at it's
really funny on twitter you see all the
leftists with their like electoral
college predictions
and it's like joe biden 350 something
donald trump like two you know 210
and then you have uh all the right-wing
people it's inverted it's like donald
trump 3-0 something and
you know whatever i will say though
trafalgar group
on november 8 2016 tweeted out the exact
electoral college breakdown
trump 306 clinton 232 and then
uh a day later the results came in
they got three states wrong they said
wisconsin was gonna be
i think uh uh red or i i don't know i
don't know which one uh
i think yeah yeah they said new
hampshire would be red and wisconsin
would be blue
and nevada would be red but uh nevada
and new hampshire i think went blue but
wisconsin went red giving trump the
extra 10.
that put them to 306. so no one knows
what's going to happen
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you